looking closely at the silhouettes of  the beings about to break through into  our reality we see a silhouette carrying  a spear which appears to be spider-man  rogue craven the hunter this looks like  the rogue with the deadly singing tale  scorpion and last but not least this  image looks like the obscure but fan  favorite six-armed spider-man the  grungily modest studio apartment peter  inhabits is a callback to toby's  spider-man 2 apartment and the one peter  could barely afford in the original  comics peter sewing his own suit is a  callback to the comic's creation of his  first spider suit the color and design  of peter's latest suit at the end of the  film is most similar to the original  look created by steve ditko in the  comics  you